[Music]
[Music]
a westminster drama of the most
breathtaking kinda leader unwilling to
go a party and parliament determined to
force him out
and today boris johnson finally gave in
but when he leaves downing street is
still uncertain
i'm dermot monaghan live in downing
street with a special program
downfall of a prime minister
polarizing and pugnacious right to the
end but boris johnson finally admits it
is over
it is clearly now the will of the
parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister
as his wife daughter aides and mps watch
on he applauds his achievements and
addresses his supporters
i want you to know how sad i am
to be giving up
the best job in the world
that them's the brakes
so boris johnson will go but not yet
meeting his latest cabinet and pledging
to wait until a successor is chosen
well over the next hour we'll hear what
politicians and their general public
make of that and hear their reaction to
his form
from that red bust get brexit done
there's no doubting boris johnson's
impact though many question the way he
did it
a liar a showman
a buffoon
a rank incompetent
and probably
the most shameful prime minister that
britain has ever had
and the battle to be next wallace sunac
trusts and the rest though we may have
to wait until the autumn
[Music]
a very good evening from downing street
where boris johnson's downfall was
finally confirmed today the prime
minister resigned though he isn't going
quietly he blamed the herd among mps for
forcing him out and said he would stay
in place until a successor is chosen
well many at westminster are now trying
to make that happen as quickly as
possible the vying to take over has
already begun while others joined the
prime minister's again reshuffled
cabinet well tonight we'll look at the
johnson legacy the parts of the country
that he helped his party win for the
first time
and hear some of the international
reaction to his demise but first our
political editor beth rigby reports on
the day that saw a prime minister's
downfall
still a spring in his step but this now
the end of the road for boris draxler
his wife and other die-hard supporters
in full applause still
but it couldn't mask the mood these mps
comforting each other as they came to
witness something they fought hard not
to see as did he but after days of
defiance the prime minister now
reluctantly relenting
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister and i've agreed with segren
brady the chairman of our back bench mps
that the process of choosing that new
leader should begin now
accepting new leadership now necessary
but fast appointed reminder of what this
leader achieved thank you
for that incredible mandate
the biggest conservative majority since
1987
the biggest share of the vote
since
1979.
and making it very clear to the public
that he neither wanted nor in his mind
deserved to go in the last few days i've
tried to persuade my colleagues that it
would be eccentric to change governments
when we're delivering so much i regret
and not to have been successful in those
arguments and of course it's painful and
not to be able to see
through
so many ideas and projects myself but as
we've seen
at westminster
the herd instinct is powerful when the
herd moves it moves and my friends in
politics no one is remotely
indispensable
acknowledging then he couldn't carry on
but mr johnson true to himself until the
very end no remorse and no mention even
that this was a resignation what he did
offer up was regret
i know that there will be many people
who are relieved
and
perhaps quite a few who will also be
disappointed
and i want you to know how sad i am
to be giving up
the best job in the world
that them's the brakes even if things
can sometimes
seem dark now
our future together
is golden
thank you all very much
thank you
and with that the johnson era drew to a
close turning his back on a bruising
period
outside the downing street gates chance
of liar and a sense of fury but it was
descent on the inside that caused his
downfall an avalanche of resignation
letters triggered by previously loyal
mps even the new chancellor nadim
zahawit not resigning but urging boris
johnson to go from the very top to the
bottom staunch allies call in time
when i made that decision to resign as a
parliamentary private secretary which i
appreciate is at the very bottom of the
uh the ladder in terms of ministerial
roles uh i i knew that once i made that
decision that it was the right decision
i haven't regretted it once i'm just sad
that it came to this because i think he
is a good person instinctively and i
think that he could have been and should
have been a great prime minister but
sadly just some poor choices uh over too
long a time it just meant his position
was untenable
but the business of running the country
goes on the prime minister appointing a
new cabinet yet even those in post
wondering what comes next but clear of
one thing policy decisions are now out
of the prime minister's hands here's the
thing this is a caretaker government
it's not the business of this prime
minister to start announcing new
policies or taking government into a
different direction it's his business to
manage a transition in an orderly way
and through that process actually redeem
some of the ground that he clearly lost
yesterday when he stubbornly refused to
resign so he's an administrator rather
than a leader at this point i think he
has to be
but that task now so difficult
department after department deserted i
just worry that he isn't going to be
able to bring the stability that we need
he's got a chancellor who's already said
he doesn't have any confidence in him
and two or three other members of the
cabinet the attorney general is
outwardly campaigning for his job it's a
it's just not a credible way to form a
government boris johnson will always be
remembered as the politician that
brought brexit to great britain at his
height he was the most successful
conservative party leader at the ballot
box since the days of margaret thatcher
he won a huge mandate and had it in his
gift to lead this country for a decade
or more that was the plan but it didn't
turn out like that instead he finds
himself leaving office and as one of the
shortest serving prime ministers in the
history of his country a man who in the
end let his party and his people down a
politician who is as talented and
charismatic as he is flawed and
destructive in the end it was boris
johnson who brought himself down
and even on the way out the opposition
trying to hasten his departure they've
declared him unfit to be prime minister
they can't inflict him on the country
for the next few months if they don't
get rid of him we will bring that vote
of no confidence
in the national interest because we
can't go on with this broken government
led by this discredited prime minister
westminster left reeling after the most
extraordinary 48 hours in recent british
political history this a dramatic end to
a dramatic premiership boris johnson is
defiant in giving up power as he was in
taking it and a politician who will
always be remembered if not always for
the right reasons
and beth's here with me right now live
in downing street and beth you were
there six and a half hours ago or so
when the prime minister made that speech
i want to ask you what that tells us
about the tussle the battle to actually
get him out because he talked about
unrelenting sledging a herd mentality
how it would be eccentric to change
governments he clearly still thinks he
really shouldn't be going
i
think that that speech was sort of
vintage boris johnson in the sense that
he to the very end to the final speech
of his premiership in any meaningful
sense
he
admitted
no remorse
he was unapologetic really about what
had happened
and really put the blame if you like
onto others making it clear
in that speech
that he had not wanted to go that he had
been forced
out
what it had though was a tinge of
sadness i thought there was regret there
regret that he was having to give up the
best job in the world as he put it but
it was clear in that speech
that boris johnson
didn't want to step down that he had
that mandate from the public that he
felt had earned him the right to see out
his term but if you step back
from these
extraordinary events it is
genuinely mind-blowing to me
that this man who was so effective in
2019 you and i were there when the
results came in we were covering uh the
election for sky news and both of us
thought he might win but did we predict
an 80-seat majority and the total
trouncing of the labour party no we did
not and so he had this mandate to sort
of reshape great britain to perhaps
serve two terms maybe even
three he had in his grasp the chance of
being the most
prominent
and influential
post-war prime minister and he
squandered it
will obviously continue for quite some
time to the here and now about who's
going to replace him he seems to think
he may last summer out and it may take
until the autumn there are others in the
party who say we've got to get this done
very quickly indeed yeah i i was talking
to robert buckland you saw him in that
piece there now the welsh secretary and
i said to him number one can boris
johnson actually stay on until september
or october
and robert buckland said to me to be
frank with you i don't know in that
there are moves within the party uh to
try and put a caretaker prime minister
in but the point of that is they would
have to get the cabinet
to descent once more and push him out
and i thought what was interesting and i
want to read this to you is the way in
which they have shifted so rapidly from
boris johnson being in office but in no
sense at all now being in power in any
meaningful way and at the cabinet
meeting at 3pm the statement here is
that the prime minister made it clear
the government would not seek to
implement new policies or make major
changes of direction he said major
fiscal decisions should be left for the
next prime minister so that was the deal
with the cabinet people saying to him we
will stay on and serve you know the
country needs a chance it needs a health
secretary and so on uh on the basis that
you make no serious policy decisions
between now and then so he is of you
like an administrator rather than a
leader and i think that that might be
enough to assuage at least the cabinet
from kicking him out and then i guess
the next question dermot is uh
how quickly does this happen and who
replaces him a couple of quick thoughts
on that in terms of the timetable i
think there's a move now for the 22 back
bench committee to try and kick this off
really quickly perhaps even get to the
final two candidates before recess on
july the 21st like to do that is going
to be a race that they might make it
quite a high threshold of supporters
that you need to formally launch a bid
when it's teresa may you needed six
backers it might be that they make it 10
15 even 20. could have a new prime
minister by september okay beth thank
you very much andy beth would be our
political editor well if boris johnson
is removed fairly soon his will be the
shortest live conservative premiership
since neville chamberlain who of course
was replaced by winston churchill now mr
johnson wants to stay on though until a
successor is chosen rather than give way
to a caretaker leader as we've been
discussing like his deputy dominick rahm
but whatever happens the process to
replace him is now underway right now
and let's take you through how it works
as things stand the prime minister can
approach the queen at any time to
request that she appoint someone else as
interim leader but at the moment boris
johnson is staying as a caretaker prime
minister until a new one is chosen to
take part in the race a conservative mp
needs to be nominated by eight
colleagues then all conservative mps
vote in a series of rounds whittling the
list of candidates down the person who
receives the fewest votes in each round
is eliminated voting then continues
until only two candidates remain and
then that's the end of the mps role then
party members get to make their final
choice before a deadline set by the 1922
committee of conservative backbenchers
and then a new prime minister is
installed it's thought the current plan
is for this to happen as beth was
telling us at least by the time of the
conservative party conference that
starts at the beginning of october
there is disquiet though over how long
all that might take for the next prime
minister to be chosen as our deputy
political editor sam coats reports
boris johnson standing down but not
leaving
still in office he says for weeks to
come until a new leader walks through
the number 10 door mps are worrying if
they can wait that long the last 48
hours his refusal to accept reality has
done a lot of damage um to
trust in the institution as a whole in
in parliament in in conventions that we
have in the conservative party he has
lost the confidence of the party that's
absolutely apparent and therefore it's
not appropriate that we have anything
other than a proper caretaker
administration a new cabinet is in place
promising no surprises in the coming
weeks a bare bones government facing so
many crises
the biggest war in europe for decades
skyrocketing bills stalling the economy
and a health service battling a
crippling covered backlog all pushing
the conservative party to move at speed
you could have the hustings over the
next couple of weeks the house rises in
two weeks time you've got two full
parliamentary weeks to have the hustings
at which point there could be two
candidates emerge there will be two
candidates that emerge and they're the
two that go before the membership the
question then is whether the second
place candidate if they're really well
behind the first place candidate will
decide to step aside
a former prime minister used to party
insurrection urging haste too
in a damning letter sir john major wrote
the proposal for the prime minister to
remain in office is unwise and may be
unsustainable some will argue his new
cabinet will restrain him i merely note
that his previous cabinet did not or
could not do so
the bond of trust between boris johnson
and the conservative party is now
fundamentally broken yet he remains in
office for weeks if not months
jostling to succeed him has already
begun but the manner of his downfall
could create a whiplash that results in
a very different successor who takes the
country in a new direction
an mp who voted remain and has never
served in government tom tugan hat
immediately endorsed by the leader of
the moderate wing of the party i think
we need
a fresh start
and in particular we need to restore
trust uh in governments not just in this
government or a conservative government
but in the way we do government uh more
widely and i think having somebody who's
not in the cabinet which is offered the
follow-up question well he's not in the
cabinet i think that's an advantage
there will be many contenders to be the
next prime minister but leadership
contests deepen divisions and expose
weakness in a party that has already
spent months tearing itself apart sam
coates sky news westminster
well let's take a closer look at who the
most likely candidates are to replace
boris johnson uh you just saw a few of
them there so both the former chancellor
rishi sunak as well as the foreign
secretary liz truss have both at times
been favorites over the last couple of
years to be the next prime minister also
among those presumed to be in the
running are the former health
secretaries sanjit javid and jeremy hunt
who's currently chair of the health and
social care committee and you probably
noticed last night the attorney general
suella bravaman confirmed that she would
run to become leader although she's
still in post sitting around that
cabinet table also in the frame would be
the current chancellor and former
education secretary nadim zahawi but the
leading candidates at the moments with
the conservative membership appears to
be the defense secretary ben wallace as
i say the most popular cabinet minister
after a poll today amongst conservative
party members and also as well it should
be added in public polls
so who will the conservative party
choose well the mp caroline knox joins
me now from westminster good to talk to
you caroline knox um well i won't ask
you for your choice yet but uh maybe
later i want to ask you of course though
about how quickly it all takes place do
you have concerns about boris johnson
remaining as prime minister for two or
three months
well i certainly have concerns about a
protracted process and i would agree
with sir charles walker who was a very
experienced parliamentarian and made the
point that
mps have two full sitting weeks of
parliament to go before the summer
recess there is no reason why we
couldn't have whittled it down to the
final two contenders in those weeks and
then go out to a membership ballot this
could all be done and dusted within a
month
including the membership ballot well i
suppose you know if you if you're
gathered in westminster what you could
have two or three ballots a day i can
see how you can whittle it down to the
two candidates but then don't they have
to be hustings and those candidates have
to make their pitches to the membership
and last time around that took what six
weeks wasn't it
well look didn't we learn a massive
amount through
the pandemic what you could achieve via
uh visum and i think that we could do
online hustings i don't have a problem
with that at all um perhaps the party
could get into the 21st century and have
an online ballot so you didn't have to
worry about postal ballots being
returned and i think it's really
important that we crack on with the
process get this over and done with we
don't need any more dither and delay we
need to have a new leader taking us in a
direction towards the next general
election whenever that comes
and why do you think that because i did
ask you do you have concerns about mr
johnson remaining i mean you clearly had
concerns about him being prime minister
you've been wanting him to go for quite
some time do you think it's
there's a danger
in letting him stay
it feels very unsatisfactory previously
when we've had
prime ministers who stood down they've
acted in a caretaker role until such
time as their successor has been chosen
but they haven't stood down in quite the
circumstances that
uh the boris johnson has we saw theresa
may couldn't get her brexit deal through
we saw david cameron stand down after
the referendum i think it's really
important that we reflect on exactly why
it is that members lost trust in boris
johnson and i would be very happy to see
dominic rob the deputy prime minister
stand in as prime minister during the
the interregnum as it were uh he did a
fine job when boris johnson was in
hospital with kovid and i think he's
sort of safe pair of hands who could
steer us through the next few weeks
without this sort of cloud and question
hanging over him
and can i ask you this carolina it's
about this idea of a caretaker
government and it more or less not doing
very much uh and just looking after the
shop because you're a politician you
know that events often define how
politicians react and you know the uk
could face let's say an economic crisis
the eurozone italy's about to go
bankrupt the eurozone could blow up who
knows what president putin could do he's
often threatening to extend the war
beyond the borders of ukraine this
government may have to make some very
big calls with boris johnson leading it
well look i think we've seen some good
people go into government in the last
few hours greg clark i certainly think
will be an incredibly safe pair of hands
at communities i was pleased to see rob
buckland go back in but some important
characters some important individuals i
would particularly highlight ben wallace
in his job as defense secretary we've
had consistency and stability there so
i'm not worried about immediate
decisions that have to be taken i would
be worried if this were to drag on for
months and months so i look at october
which seems a very long way away and i
would much prefer us to have this matter
settled as quickly as we possibly could
and a new prime minister in place to
make those big decisions to make those
big calls
and have you signed up to a leadership
campaign yet
well look i think that there are a
variety of colleagues who are coming out
and setting their stalls both publicly
and privately what matters to me is that
we have somebody with ability and
integrity we have somebody
experienced i think when you look at
some of the challenges that we're facing
uh particularly when it comes to ukraine
i think that it would be very helpful to
us to have people who had an
understanding of defence i think that
really matters but i also want a safe
pair of hands with the economy but above
all else i want somebody who i can trust
to do the right thing to do
to make the decisions that are in the
country's interests i want somebody
who's going to be
honest determined and is going to set
out a really clear vision for where they
think the country should be going
good talking to you caroline oaks thank
you very much indeed
well of course boris johnson famously
once said he wanted to be world king
well he may not have reached quite that
height but we'll leave office with
britain in a very different place to
where it would have been of course
without him his role during the pandemic
can be contested his central role in
taking the country out of the european
union certainly cannot our home editor
jason farrell reflects now on the prime
minister's legacy
are we ready
the biggest character in modern british
politics
who in beating his way to number 10 this
whole debate is about democracy took the
country out of the eu
you must stay at home
in office he was confronted with one of
the deadliest challenges ever faced by
any prime minister covid19
but was the downfall of this great
showman that he simply couldn't survive
being seen for who he really was
a liar a showman
a buffoon
a rank incompetent
and probably
the most shameful prime minister that
britain has ever had and somebody the
like of whom i pray we will never see
again i've always liked boris johnson
he's got a real earnest concern for the
british people and they feel it and it's
because they feel it that they love him
so much
well what a tragedy that we've come to
this but we've come to this by his own
hand i'm sorry to say in a way this will
be as always a personal tragedy you know
that the very
many of the factors that brought boris
johnson to be prime minister are also
responsible for his fall
johnson set out in life to be a winner
as a child his stated ambition was world
king and his method self-belief even if
not everything he said was true
as a journalist he was sacked from the
times for misrepresentation and in
politics was sacked again from his first
front bench role for lying about an
affair
but with celebrity appeal and a radar
for popular policy he became london's
first conservative mayor dubbed the
heineken politician reaching parts other
tories couldn't thank you for sticking
up for london and for the innocent
hard-working people of this city
so why not reach number 10.
whether he believed in brexit or not
joining vote leave provided a platform
and a policy that appealed to many
grassroots tories and while theresa may
had first stab at delivering brexit
boris johnson is elected as the leader
of the conservative and unionist party
he convinced the tories and then the
electorate that his so-called oven-ready
deal was better
[Applause]
i think that his strengths
really lay in campaigning i think had he
picked a
particularly strong team around him
and enabled himself to do more of the
campaigning while others did more of the
governing i think he might still be in
place
his rise had been on the sale of
optimism so his initial approach to the
pandemic was the same i was at a
hospital the other night where i think
there were a few there were actually a
few coronavirus patients and i shook
hands with everybody you'll be pleased
to know accused of being slow to lock
down he succumbed to the virus
meanwhile his controversial advisor
dominic cummings broke the rules then
his apparent rivalry with the prime
minister's new bride carrie johnson led
to him being cut loose instantly
becoming his former boss's fiercest
critic
tens of thousands of people died who
didn't need to die but johnson had got
brexit done albeit with stored-up
problems in northern ireland
his next success was on the vaccine
rollout it was world beating far faster
than the eu he'd won an 80-seat majority
and he'd been quick to support ukraine
against aggression from russia and for
those reasons supporters forgave his
failings for as long as they could his
initial support for owen patterson who
was guilty of lobbying while accepting
cash the donor funded refurbishment of
his flat above number 11 the number 10
parties during lockdown and the
inconsistencies over what the prime
minister knew nobody said to me this is
an event that is against the rules
still a police investigation fined him
for breaching his own laws he thought he
could play it all as he has all his life
ever since he was a school boy
at eaton he thought he could do it his
own way and he found out and and
many many people said from the very
beginning
that it would go wrong the question was
only when
when deputy chief whip chris pincher
stood down after allegations of sexual
harassment it emerged the pm had been
warned of previous behavior
he denied knowing then when it was clear
he did said he'd forgotten his
chancellor and health secretary had had
enough and set in chain a crumbling of
his support when you're choosing any
leader there are uncertainties you don't
know how things will turn out there is
there is risk in every instance but
he did deliver
brexit as he promised he did deliver
election victory as well
and and as i've said there are
significant achievements during his
premiership it
despite you know the
you know the
very negative circumstances of of recent
weeks the man who could reach the parts
others couldn't was plunging to the
depths pulling his party with him
it took a damagingly long time for them
and him
to let go jason farrell sky news
now a couple of illustrations of just uh
how quickly boris johnson is cracking on
with forming his new government a couple
more ministerial appointments to tell
you about first of all johnny mercer has
been uh appointed minister for veterans
affairs former soldier of course johnny
mercer long campaigned on those issues
he will attend cabinets we are hearing
and an illustration of anyone needed
just what an extraordinary week this has
been because will quince is back in
government i think after about what
three days out of it back in
as a minister at the department of
education now you remember will quince
on monday how long ago that seems on
monday was sent out to defend the prime
minister over the chris pincher affair
and was briefed by downing street he
said in his resignation letter that he
thought he'd been misled by number 10
downing street and then that whole ball
started rolling well will quince is
back there in the department of
education as a minister of state
well to the economy now and boris
johnson told his cabinet today he
wouldn't make any major changes to
policy all big fiscal decisions
now the backdrop for his final days or
weeks in power will be the same as that
for whoever succeeds him of course a
cost of living crisis and a premiership
which saw the highest increase in public
debt of any modern prime minister our
data and economics editor ed conway
analyzes the economic challenges now
facing the government
so now we have more of a sense of what's
going on with the politics but what
about the economics well here there's a
couple of things to look at first of all
how do people view the uk uh as an
investment now you can get a sense of
that by looking at what's going on in
currency markets remember during brexit
how it was kind of going around up and
down depending on what was going on with
that roller coaster well here the funny
thing is it was moderately stable in the
last few days really weak the pound
right now against most other currencies
but it didn't seem to be moving until we
got that news that boris johnson was
going to resign when that news broke
just look at what happened to sterling
against the dollar it shot up and now it
is a fair bit stronger than it was
before so there's a bit of kind of
stability premium there people relieved
that we know a little bit more about
what's going to happen now but of course
the big question is what are they going
to do about economic policy what can
they do
and one of the big things they want to
address is this both the chancellor new
chancellor andy boris johnson have
talked a lot about the tax burden and
the fact that is getting up to the
highest level that we've seen since the
1940s that's the rate at which we pay
tax basically as a percentage of gdp and
look at how high that's going up
but here's the issue they want to cut
that but for some people the pressure
might be in the other direction the
office for budget responsibility they're
the people the government's kind of
official forecasters they produce this
bit of analysis just now looking at the
change in long-term deficit as a result
of things happening recently so
basically the higher these bars are the
more the deficit is going to go up you
can see the fiscal position actually
that's improved a bit recently but look
over to the other side so demography is
a bit worse so fewer people being born
so less people to to pay taxes net zero
the cost of net zero means that fewer
taxes are coming in petrol taxes uh and
then you've got social care and other
factors as well and you stack all of
that up and you're talking about quite a
lot of extra costs in fact
about 37 billion pounds worth if you
wanted to get net debt so the total
national debt down to the levels it was
before the pandemic you need to raise
taxes by 37 billion pounds not cut them
and that is a lot so that's one concern
uh for the prime minister leaving aside
whether he's actually able to pass any
of his legislation
but overshadowing everything is this
inflation this shows you the inflation
rate across the g7 so major economies
around the world everyone thought that
we had tamed it that it was going to be
low forever and look at what happened it
has risen to the highest level we've
seen since the early 1980s and the uk
that red line is the highest of all so
it's that cost of living crisis that is
going to remain
the big economic challenge in the next
few months
ed conway there well now before he was
prime minister boris johnson was of
course no stranger on the world stage
having served as foreign secretary under
his predecessor recently it was in that
realm that mr johnson found refuge from
troubles here at home he immersed
himself in the diplomacy surrounding the
war in ukraine a major player in the
european push to support president
zielenski
but it was fraught relations with the
european union that will leave many on
the continent now glad to see the back
of him uh international affairs editor
dominic wagon looks at boris johnson's
international legacy
prime minister boris johnson a key ally
announces that he is resigning
to the americans a key ally to the
germans a scandal noodle or glutton for
scandal whatever they called the prime
minister his spectacular demise has
seized the world's attention
from the start he was a different kind
of statesman for some a refreshing
change of character for others reason to
pity britain for european allies the way
he's pursued brexit has been a constant
cause of frustration and anger the fact
is that uh
the under boris johnson the british
government could not be relied upon or i
would say it could be relied upon to be
unreliable
he wants to critics too deferential to
donald trump who called him a british
version of himself you know this is does
everybody know he's going to be a
fantastic prime minister
but he maintained close relations with
his successor too on ukraine in
particular
but viewed from the other side of the
atlantic his scandal-prone time in
office has ultimately not been good for
britain's place in the world he's very
intelligent he's extremely engaging but
as a political leader he's also been
deeply narcissistic and hasn't been good
for the united kingdom and so even if
the americans miss him we have to
recognize that this has been a bad
period for uk politics it has been beset
with scandal upon scandal upon scandal
boris johnson has been caught in lie
after lie after lie and they don't need
this
not so in ukraine though where he was
one of the first leaders to visit after
the war began he's seen as the most
dependable of allies in government and
on the street where they reacted with
regret to the news of his resignation we
are
sad because of it we
seen him come here in kiev i think it's
a big mistake for ukraine because it's
boris johnson is our big friend
not surprisingly johnson's legacy on
ukraine is a part of his record one
favourite to succeed him wants to
preserve he has led from the front on
ukraine as he had on covid and obviously
brexit and i think that isn't lost on
many people but the whole of the
political system is supportive of what
we're doing in ukraine i don't expect
that to finish at all
most recently boris johnson seemed more
at ease on the world stage away from his
troubles back home
and like other leaders before him may
well be remembered more fondly abroad
than at home dominic waghorn sky news
well we can speak to the former chair of
the brexit select committee labour's
hillary ben good to talk to you mr ben
now good evening today uh your leader
kiyostama described this as
a government that wasn't functioning
does it seem now that the engines are
firing up again we've got a a new
cabinet they met this afternoon and a
continuing slew of ministerial
appointments
well the jobs are clearly being filled
after the extraordinary events of the
last few days i mean it was inevitable
that his premiership was held below the
water line
and finally he
he bowed to that inevitability but
listening to his speech today there was
no self-awareness no self-criticism and
he was
i think he blamed the westminster herd
for not understanding what a what a
wonderful prime minister he was i think
his premiership will be looked at as
bad for britain bad in the world as as
we've just been reporting and there's a
very telling comment in your earlier
package
where your reporter said whether he
believed it or not and i think brexit is
a really good example because as you
know dermot he very famously wrote two
articles one in favor of staying in the
european union and one in favor of
leaving and decided to publish the
latter and i think
he probably thought we'll lose the
referendum but i will position myself
well to become the next leader of the
conservative party and i think the only
thing boris johnson has really believed
in
is himself
and i'm relieved that he has okay
i mean just while we're on that subject
and given the long discussions that you
and i used to have during those um
brexit years if i can term than that
since 2016. can i take it though now
that labour is now endorsing boris
johnson's approach to brexit after that
speech by kia stammer last week saying
that labour does not now support
rejoining the single market the customs
union certainly not
the european union and that then
therefore i suppose a few tweaks to the
northern ireland protocol and you'd be
in lockstep
no we're not in lockstep i mean i
haven't changed my mind about brexit i
think it was a profound mistake and we
are now seeing the economic
consequences in the modern world the
best way to exercise your sovereignty is
in partnership with others to defend and
advance the interests of your people
that is a fundamental truth of
international affairs at the beginning
of the 21st century but look he's made a
terrible hash of the northern ireland
protocol we desperately need to get this
sorted because there is no functioning
government in northern ireland and
the government has got to change tag but
so is the commission and i've been
critical of the commission i've said to
them you have got to move because this
is a political problem that requires a
political solution no i think what kia
said was very simply to recognize a fact
and the fact is we have left
i don't think there is a public appetite
to have another referendum which would
be required to rejoin the single market
in my view the customs union or the eu
and that isn't going to happen and we
need to turn our attention to the new
question which is how do we build
a new but different relationship with
our european friends and neighbors we've
got to make trade easier we've got to
deal with the bureaucracy and red tape
the boris johnson's deal has dumped on
the heads of british business but that
isn't going to happen okay while the
northern ireland protocol is a bone of
contention and we need a different
approach to that to get it sorted it's
perfectly doable
but you need the right politics okay and
mr ben can i just ask you specifically
then has labour's threat now that boris
johnson has announced his resignation of
course he hasn't gone yet but that that
threat from labour to call a vote of no
confidence in the house that's that's
gone away you'll you'll settle for the
process taking place within the
conservative party
well i am i am but a humble backbencher
these days and that's the question you
ought to direct to the labour front
bench i think uh maybe the conservative
party will decide they need as quicker
process as possible of electing a new
leader and therefore a new prime
minister because
i think everybody and
conservative mps the rest of the country
have had enough of boris johnson and
we've also had enough of 12 years of
conservative government and those tory
mps who put him in his job doing exactly
what he was like
they can't now say oh well we argued for
him to be removed they were complicit in
everything that he did and we need a
change and i hope that will come soon
so do you get a sense then that i mean
you hope to pin this around the
conservative party party when you do
fight them at the next general election
boris johnson's legacy they of course
will want a clean skin a new leader with
uh maybe a bit of a new appointment
bounce and presumably go to the country
one would imagine sometime next year
well that's a very interesting question
dermot because whoever becomes prime
minister william harry a majority of 80
and he or she will
probably wish to be pretty sure that
they could do better than that before
they take the risk on a general election
remember the last conservative prime
minister who tried that lost her
majority all together look whenever the
election comes we're going to be ready
to fight it under kirsten the new
leadership the new direction and i i
think we're approaching the moment where
after 12 years remember in a long
waiting lists to see these gp queues to
get your operations done concerns about
security the need to get the economy
moving these are all reasons why i hope
the british people will look at labor
and say you know what it is now time for
a change and i can't wait for that
moment to arrive we have to win people's
trust and confidence but we're ready to
do our best to achieve that
and this isn't one of the problems with
that mr ben is that you say yes 12 years
time for a change it's a very potent as
we all know political slogan wherever
it's deployed around the world but some
the problem is that this conservative
party with its variety of leaders during
the 12 years it's been in power
continues therefore to reinvent itself
and one of boris johnson's biggest
tricks if i could call it that was to
more or less say to the british public
that this is an entirely new government
and had nothing to do with the previous
austerity one
well he he did and uh i mean the
contradiction at the heart of the
conservative
party and the conservative government
which we will see play out in the
leadership election is on the one hand
they all stand up and say we are low
taxing conservatives and on the other
hand we've got a huge tax burden at the
moment on the british people and they're
gonna have to decide how they reconcile
the two but after the years of uh george
osborne and david cameron's austerity i
don't think there's any appetite for
that we are going into a really
difficult winter for so many people in
this country worried about bills rising
food prices and they will be looking to
see have we got a government that's on
our side or not and that is where the
fight will be held whenever the election
comes because in tough times people look
to the government to help them and we
stand ready to rise to that challenge if
we're given the opportunity
very good talking to you as always mr
ben thank you very much
hillary been
well it was the so-called red wall that
propelled boris johnson to a seemingly
unassailable position as we were
mentioning there in 2019 there once
labor heartlands where many voters turn
to the conservatives partly on a promise
of getting brexit done and delivered the
prime minister an 80-seat majority no
less so have the recent scandal so the
party gate pinscher seen those voters
turn away or will they miss boris
johnson the skies katarina vitozi has
been to bolton to hear the red wall
reaction there to the prime minister's
demise
[Music]
this is 96.5
bolton fm
boris johnson has resigned as prime
minister after less than three years in
office
it was constituencies like bolton north
east in greater manchester that got
boris johnson into power
part of the so-called labour red wall
that in 2019
turned blue when you come to a
constituency like this one which turned
conservative for the first time in
decades back in 2019 and you ask people
why did you vote conservative you'll
often hear three things first that they
believed what the conservative party was
saying about brexit then about levelling
up but really it's because people say
they light boris johnson
and that inspired some people to vote
conservative for the very first time
hello like ann griffis who lives at a
very different number 10 with her
bulldog winston
he was a big character and he said what
he felt sometimes it was wrong maybe it
wasn't politically correct who gives a
damn i still think he cares passionately
about england and wales and scotland and
northern ireland and do you believe
there is anyone else within the
conservative party that would persuade
you to vote for the party again no
quite simply no and the reason i have
fought so hard in the last few days and
the loss of those votes could be
significant the tory mp here won in 2019
by the slimmest of margins his
supporters fear he wouldn't win again
i'm very disappointed because
i think the red ball
constituencies are just going to go back
to being labor
because uh boris brought the red world
down and he got he got their attention
and who wanted him working-class people
actually wanted to work on the safety
for the first time
i think that's lost now
how did you feel seeing the resignation
speech today it was a bittersweet moment
i think people have expected it for a
long time
will bruce has always voted labour but
today for him it didn't feel like a day
to celebrate i think he needs to go now
i think me to
actually have a a real change of
leadership
so that basically we can actually kind
of deal with the issues of the country
that have been
like with inflation and fuel crisis
especially in a poor working class down
like bolton this is a place with many
social challenges for some the prime
minister's resignation feels like a
relief
since the prime minister was found to a
bridge the rules he set up himself i
think he should have gone really i don't
know why they kept him there he was just
a lame dog
more or less really it's a bit of hope
now that somebody else could be there
that we have a new team that is going to
give people hope and more confidence for
the conservative party the pressure is
now on to find a leader who can make
sure that votes lent in 2019
return next time
catering for totsi sky news in bolton
well joining me now is camilla cavadish
the former director of the number 10
policy unit for david cameron now a
member of the house of lords very good
to see you and uh welcome back to
downing street i'm sure you've been back
since then
let me put the same question more or
less that i put to hillary bed because
labor termed this
government over the last few days as a
not functioning one you also felt that
that was happening i mean it has been an
extraordinary few days does it feel
though now like it is beginning to
function again we've got a new cabinet
new ministerial appointments and the
same prime minister yes so you're
beginning to get the vacancies filled
i mean there was one point this morning
i think when we had nobody in the
department of education uh running
schools um so in principle there are
posts that are filled there is a
manifesto there is legislation still
going through parliament
um
however i think i've felt from quite a
few months that the government hasn't
really been functioning very well under
boris johnson because fundamentally
he came to power as a revolutionary and
a great campaigner and he has never
quite figured out how to govern
why do you think that happened why did
he lose his umph his
desire to shake things up as we saw of
course during the referendum campaign i
think he has never taken the time
to
understand execution and really care
about policy detail i mean i'm a policy
wonk i happen to care about these things
but the truth is
you can be mayor of london you can be a
star and an entertainer and have great
political instincts which he did
you can't be prime minister in this
building unless you're prepared to work
hours and hours of the day and read all
of your briefs
and think very very deeply about really
quite detailed areas you're probably
taking 20 25 decisions a day okay but
isn't it about the people you put around
you and listening to them because boris
johnson brought a lot of people a lot of
people who've worked so effectively with
him as mayor of london okay different
running a country but you put the good
people around you but you've got to
listen to them haven't you because i
want to put you that will remember i
used to stand out here when david
cameron was in there and say well he's
got a bit of a reputation for chillaxing
and he's perhaps not entirely engaged at
all times but it's the people around you
but we would put the
red boxes together at 10 o'clock at
night and by 8 o'clock in the morning we
would come here and we would have the
meeting and he would have gone through
every single one of those papers and he
would have made decisions
and that's what good prime minister does
um you can have great people around you
but you've got to set a clear direction
i think one of boris johnson's flaws has
been he likes to be liked he finds it
very hard to make difficult trade-offs
and i think a lot of people have felt
he's been only as good as the last
person he talked to
changed his mind very very often and out
right out the rest of whitehall there
are thousands of people who work here
and they need clarity and we have not
had that really for three years
and then now this weird transition from
active prime minister to caretaker prime
minister you know there may be some big
calls as i was saying earlier to make
whether you like them or not yes
how does he handle that well david
cameron did stay on we stayed on for a
while until theresa may came on he was
very careful not to bind the hands of
her successor he held off a lot of
policy announcements that we've been
planning to make but you do still have
the levers of power and i do think that
what sir john major said earlier today
that it might be unwise to let boris
johnson be the caretaker because he
hasn't actually got the confidence in
the house of commons was probably true
so
you are in the camp that said there
should be an interim prime minister a
dominic robb is being made you need a
dominic rob type character who is not
going to stand for the leadership but
who can keep the machine running and be
a respected
certificate let me talk
let me talk to you about this loss of
authority so there's a loss of authority
in this country there's an even bigger
one internationally where let's say
relations with so many countries has
been pretty fraught to say the very
least aren't they now just going to i
mean ignore him all together we we know
you're going we don't need to deal with
you well that's true once you stand
there and give the speech he gave this
morning the power drains out of the
building
and yeah the world leaders stop calling
on the whole um because everybody knows
this happens in every country
you're a dead man walking at that point
and the tories have to get on and have a
swift leadership contest and install
somebody who can take the party forward
and take the country forward let's talk
about unless you want to name some names
let's talk about the character of who
should replace him certainly someone i'm
imagining you're going to tell me with a
firm grasp of ethics
what else though is required when it
comes to repairing those international
relations and of course dealing with i
was going to say looming economic crisis
the economic crisis we're in right here
and now yes i mean i think the backdrop
is really different to the backdrop we
had for the referendum i mean as you say
we have economic crisis we have the
pound sterling is sliding and sliding
inflation is up um britain is in a very
dangerous situation and i think that
actually the party needs to put aside
its differences over brexit right now
there are candidates trying to establish
their tax cutting credentials because
they think that will get them elected
with the right of the party or there are
candidates saying you know they don't
want to vote for anybody who stood for
remain i think they need to get past
that and look at the new economic
context and have a sensible programme
for economic growth which can command
confidence of business and investors and
indeed the rest of the world and i don't
think that's impossible to do by the way
so i mean ie very very serious indeed we
need a bit a bit of john major feel
about it then is it
yes perhaps i mean when um nadim zahawi
decided to take the chancellorship i
thought he was seeing himself as the
john major character who
came in and became the prime minister
actually with with quite a good
background but nobody quite knew who it
was
um i'm afraid i fear that having then
immediately written on treasury
letterhead to the prime minister asking
him to go
was too opportunistic really for him to
be the john major character but but as
you're suggesting i think i don't think
the next person needs to be a hugely
dramatic
charismatic entertainer i think we've
had quite enough of that we need
somebody who is sober and serious and
grown up and preferably has ministerial
experience and preferably has not served
in the johnson cabinet
and had to defend the indefensible for
so many years well that disqualifies so
many of the front runners i mean i was
going to you know mention you mentioned
there's somebody who has to get over
leave remain well ben wallace is the
front runner he of course was a remainer
but is incredibly popular with the
general conservative electorate but you
think he's he's been there too long his
hands are dirtied i think the general
conservative electorate is a very small
number of people um i think this
decision needs to be made by the
parliamentary party who probably have a
better sense of what will play in the
country
i'm not saying a lot of these people
like ben wallace aren't admirable people
but what i'm saying is i think apart
from rishi sunayak and satya javed who
at least had the courage to resign and
satya javid rember has resigned twice
i think anybody who stayed in the
cabinet beyond monday i'm afraid is
really tarnished because
what the next man or woman has to do
is not just corrupt an economic policy
but re-establish our faith in politics
as a country and that is a really big
ask and you have to start with that
above everything else and just in terms
of the speed of this process what's your
your take on it because you know when
the david cameron was replaced in the
end it didn't go to the conservative
membership because there was a deal done
the concern the the party whittled it
down to two andre ledsim and theresa may
and in the end a deal was done and there
was only theresa may so she just had to
be endorsed yes and i think that would
be quite a good thing i think at the
moment the danger is that half the mps
who come on your show seem to suddenly
declare that they're standing for the
leadership
and we could be seeing hundreds of these
people in a contest which is not really
helpful i think there are we all know
who the grown-ups are
there's only a handful of them and i
think the mps would be better to try and
unite around somebody
not to rush it because it does need to
be a thought out decision
but really try and unite around if not
one person at least two that they can
then
decide between
and what would your thoughts be then on
a new leader there is going to be one
certainly by the the ultimate before the
party conference at the very latest on
this issue it's always asked a new
leader
hasn't stood as leader before the the
general electorate what about a general
election then next spring something like
that for validation
i mean in a democracy that's the right
answer isn't it because essentially
we've had a number of prime ministers
now who've actually come into office
without that general election and
without that confirmation
um
i don't think it's cut and dried though
because i really do think this country
is in a national crisis i mean we are at
war with what we are in a war with
ukraine we have a cost of living crisis
we have inflation we have i mean i i i
think um
the right person
if they've said look i actually really
think i've got a plan here and i need to
have some time to execute i think that
would equally be fine
um and the labour party obviously has
not
uh itself pushed for a general election
um which would have been the democratic
alternative
camilla kavanaugh's really good talking
to you about this kavanes thank you very
much indeed former head of the policy
unit here at number 10 with david
cameron well uh of course we are
changing prime ministers uh once again
eventually uh what another dramatic day
it has been boris johnson coming out to
announce his resignation about six or
seven hours ago a few meters away from
here sorry yards uh mr johnson
and now the race is on to replace him uh
there he was watched by amongst others
his wife the race is on to replace him
we will be taking you through the
runners and riders
[Music]
[Music]
you